today's April Fool's Day if you're like
me you're waiting for someone to finally
tell us this is all one big giant prank
but it's real and it's gonna get more
real we need to stay home and stay sane
we need to hold it together and so far
we have calling this heroic is an
understatement it's not about having the
courage to stay home and do puzzles now
we are driving our economy to the far
edge of its limits in order to save our
most vulnerable lives meanwhile crime is
dropping so are thugs staying home - or
maybe social media which we often bash
has transformed into something crucial
like the my pillow guy making hospital
masks social media suddenly became
essential by allowing the separated to
join it's now the glue still now's never
been a better time to avoid media's
latest divisive offerings with the sheer
stress of this shutdown
who needs that it's hard enough but
maybe we're shedding that negativity
naturally did you notice how those TV
segments we used to see pre quarantine
have disappeared the racism sexism
gender pronouns I mean where's auntie
fall did we just stop canceling people
forever we need we may not be immune to
the media's influence but our unity has
destroyed their assessments of who we
are we're sticking together not turning
on each other we are exactly who we
think we are and who the media says we
aren't with 9/11 we sent troops to war
here we are all the troops now Team
America but unity doesn't pay the bills
or can't it it's the first of the month
you got rent mortgages utilities credit
card interests that would make Don
Corleone blush it is time for a pause
like I said in Auto Sports a yellow flag
has all drivers slowed down nobody
passes we stay in the same place and no
one overtakes another we need that here
everyone gets a bye on their bills and
that includes landlords if they're not
getting the rent in their taxes
insurance mortgages get it by two but
nothing goes out and nothing comes in
it's a freeze
imagine the economy like a remote and
you hit pause on that TV called life in
a month we could hit play and double the
speed to catch up but for now consider
it a pact among fellow citizens that way
when your grandkids ask you what you did
in the great quarantine of 2020 you can
say not much but the weirdest thing is
we did it all together Dana I have a
theory yes I've never seen this I love
your theories oh thank you I've never
seen this kind of mass cooperation on
this kind of a huge scale and I'm
beginning to think it's my fault that I
was somehow tricked being in a media
bubble to think that we all hate each
other that it's men versus women blacks
versus white gays versus straight and
that somehow this kind of American unity
was lost we are now all pockets of
identity but it seems to me that theory
has been blown out of the water for now
anyway and thankfully so right because I
do think that this what you're seeing is
the true spirit of America and it is
unfortunate that sometimes it takes a
crisis to be reminded of that but here I
loved what you said it at the end
they're like we we're not doing anything
but we're doing it all together there's
a lot to do on my show today there is a
I had a report from Molly Lyon up in
Boston and she did a she looked across
the country at food banks for example
and it was really quite overwhelming to
me and you realize that what the
government is asking us to do it's an
enormous responsibility that the
president has to weigh the information
he's getting from the health experts but
also being mindful that there's an
entire country and the well-being of the
economy and not hurt you know not doing
too much harm there and it's a very
difficult balance and it is pretty
wonderful so far to see people doing
their part and helping those people who
are on the front lines the troops are on
the front lines in the hospitals and I
like being pulled together mm-hmm it
feels good yeah Dagan I hope you notice
that I'm
like dug in a night at the Roxbury just
for you do you eat despite my theory on
this pause where nothing goes in and
nothing goes out doesn't that make sense
that if everybody is frozen and they
don't have to pay for anything nobody
falls behind nobody loses anything or a
mite like is this like a fantasy in my
brain that doesn't work well that not
together no it's not it's not a fantasy
but one other don't go there de yeah
there let me rewind the one of the
reallys go wonky but one of the reasons
the Federal Reserve is there is because
you need to make sure that these
creditors are not insolvent then you
need to make sure that people who are
owed money don't go from just having
liquidity problems to complete
insolvency because we want those jobs
right there on the other side of all of
this but there will be a pause I'm
worried about the people who are
unemployed tomorrow we're gonna get the
weekly jobless claims numbers at 8:30
a.m. we had a record number the previous
week it was almost 3.3 million people
filing for first-time unemployment
benefits tomorrow it could be five and a
half million and the unemployment
benefits the the offices in almost every
state are completely slammed and jammed
people can't even sign up they're not
getting extra money that was allocated
six hundred dollars a week for four
months from the federal government yet
and the self-employed they're having
trouble because the states are don't
acknowledge that they're eligible now
for unemployment benefits so it's a
nightmare
yet at the end of that I look at them as
individuals these are not numbers these
are people these are people who lost
their jobs overnight they're struggling
to pay their bills and put food on the
table and their families that are
suffering and not just from the virus
but from this financial crisis and we
got to think about it like that one you
know I read somewhere that 60% of the
average workers will not be able to meet
their basic financial needs
perhaps in in under a week from now how
can we simplify this process so that you
know when people are apply have to go
and they have to apply for things if
they have a small business you have to
go through so much red tape
to get the money that you need I mean
isn't there a way that we can cut
through this like we've done with other
things well I don't know I mean
obviously that's why we passed that huge
what some people want to call a stimulus
I think of it almost as a band-aid Greg
you know that it'll help people so
you'll see some of that money coming
into American pockets within a week or
so and for small business also they have
the ability to not only now get loans
but in some cases grants so I think
that's that's really important but you
know I think a lot of the tone is set by
the president in the White House and
yesterday boy I think judging by his
words what's going on has really sunk in
for the president and that helps to
bring us together to have that kind of
leadership I think it's hard for anybody
to Graf's when you see those graphs that
were put up by dr. Fauci dr. Burks and
they're talking about a hundred thousand
deaths I mean and that's the that's the
best-case scenario that's something that
can really shock you and I think say to
all of us I don't care what pocket of
America you're in this is a challenge
for us as a nation and as a people to
come to grips with it so I think that
now you're seeing some of the governors
who have been slow to say hey you know
what stay home they're starting to say
it I think that you're starting to see
now finally the understanding that this
is not the flu it's you know some people
were downplaying not the flu this is so
much more serious and has so much more
gravity in terms of potential fatalities
if you're talking about so many deaths
Jesse what are your thoughts well we're
about to hit the darkest days and
Americans are coming together but there
are people out there that are trying to
diminish our spirit so let's just look
back at the last 75 days just two and a
half months of how this thing started
just in mid-january the World Health
Organization said the virus was not
contagious people-to-people transfer was
impossible and even then the president
slapped the travel ban on China and
formed a task force and said to the
Chinese let's send our scientists to
Wuhan to investigate and China said no
and then he actually mentioned the virus
at the State of the Union address
the address that Nancy ripped up
afterwards we've gone in just a matter
of weeks from a prevention strategy to a
mitigation strategy remember January in
February it was all about the travel
bans the quarantines and eight billion
dollars March was a full-scale shutdown
and asking for two trillion dollars
doctor foul she said we got this thing
ahead of it very early and dr. Burke
said everybody thought this was a SARS
like virus coming out of China but the
Chinese lied and that's what caught us
off guard just a month ago do you know
how many deaths there were in the United
States from this virus one and three
weeks ago we were talking about the
South Carolina primary Joe Biden and
Mayor Pete was gonna drop out that's how
long ago that was
and it feels like that in our head and
not too long ago Cuomo was saying go eat
out in New York City de Blasio had all
the schools open Nancy Pelosi said bring
your friends to Chinatown and go to the
bars Joe Biden said the travel ban was
racist every column in the New York
Times The Washington Post downplayed
this thing and actually Morning Joe had
the audacity the other day to say that
everybody saw this coming in January due
nominees segments morning joe did on the
virus in january one they booked a guy
who said don't worry about this virus
worry about the flu finally everyone's
on board young people old people left
right we're all in this together now and
we need to stay together until we beat
it but i think i think you're right i
don't think morning joe ever sees
anything coming